what do you make of the last few months
of Fallout from Yale and Harvard and
such I mean yeah we saw that big uh
testimonial from the presidents yeah it
was Harvard MIT
Penn uh I mean I wasn't surprised by it
I mean a lot of people I think are
finally fully realizing they're coming
to their senses people have been saying
this for a while now oh you know
eventually the pendulum will swing back
and people will finally figure out
what's really going on in these
institutions and the sort of ideology
that's been spilling out of the
universities and now I think they
finally are actually truly realizing it
but yeah I saw the it's kind of the
birth of what a lot of people call
wokeness uh in 2015 when I arrived on
campus at Yen that was my first semester
I saw what was happening there and yeah
I mean I think you can draw a straight
line from some of those events in 2015
to what we're seeing now and yeah it's
been really ugly but you know kind of
kind of amusing you know from my
perspective because I you know I was one
of the I'd like to think that I was one
of the sort of early uh observers and
people who could recognize what was
occurring and then later on you know so
Jordan Peterson was was another and and
there have been other critics of higher
ed and especially these Elite
universities um but yeah it's been uh
really really amusing and and and also
sort of disheartening to to see it yeah
it's this this sort of odd blend
of
fatalism Shard and Freud nihilism sort
of pleasure displeasure yeah like ick
pity yeah uh it's a real concatenation
of of things and obviously we've got a
couple of mutual friends that have
either been directly or tangentially
involved Vincent uh my mutual friend I
managed to get removed from a higher
education institution because of him
appearing on this podcast Carol hoen uh
who is you know a really good mutual
friend um has kind of been thrust into
the middle of this she told me that she
basically felt like she'd been used like
a a football um and for the people who
know who Carol is she went on Rogan I
think she cried like six times on Joe's
show she cried at least three times on
mine we went for breakfast I'm pretty
sure she cried like three times at
breakfast she's just a very sort of
emotional person she is she she's really
sort of feeling this and uh yeah you
realize in a sort of proxy [__]
battle like this the people that are
useful political footballs to be kicked
around often end up paying a pretty high
price and no one ever thinks about them
because you're like oh no but you're you
know you're a flaming Warrior for free
speech or whatever and you go well yeah
but I didn't ask to be yeah yeah very
few people want to be fired I mean it's
a lot of people may not be familiar with
just how difficult it is to get an
academic job in the first place I mean I
you know I'm friends with Vincent I saw
I mean he was hustling hard and he had a
very impressive academic record and no
one wants to be in that position I think
the their their critics or their
detractors say like oh you know oh poor
me with your cancel culture and now look
at you going on all these podcasts and
playing a your victimhood and all of
this but that's not what it is I think
it's for some people it's just a
consolation that well I lost my dream
job at the very least I can sort of
communicate [__] something exactly
and yeah I was observing all of this
from afar I mean one thing that I've
pointed out before is that for every
like public academic cancellation you
see there are probably 5 to 10 others
that are not covered in the media most
people actually don't enjoy the
Limelight that much especially academics
who tend to be kind of weird nerds with
their obscure Niche interest they just
want to keep their down do their
research be left alone and then suddenly
they are accused of X Y or Z and they
just want to silently you know have it
blow over um and that's like the sort of
modal case that's the usual case um and
so yeah it's been uh we can see it now
that uh finally people are recognizing
that there's a there's a serious issue I
didn't even want to an academic job I
mean by the time I was probably about
halfway through my PhD I saw what was
happening I remember uh yeah I would
have very very contentious discussions
with other PhD students and postdocs and
kind of early career researchers and I
would tell them like I don't think that
you know if you color Outside the Lines
if you are an independent thinker it
will be very difficult for you to get a
sort of typical 10e track academic job
now um not impossible but just much
harder than it would have been maybe 10
or 15 years ago and people would say oh
no that's ridiculous it's ridiculous and
now you know four four plus years later
I'm seeing like some of those are having
difficulty some of them have been hired
and fired by now I mean it's been you
know I've seen the whole the whole
spectrum of of outcomes some of them
have successfully obtain jobs and just
you know keep their mouth shut but for
me I just that wasn't what I thought
Academia was going to be like yeah um I
thought it was going to be you know this
little kind of contained bubble you know
the I guess some people call it the
Ivory Tower right where you can live
that life of the mind and communicate
interesting ideas and debate and
disagree but still sort of inch your way
towards the truth or at least int inway
towards interesting ideas but you know
that's interestingly happening more on
places like podcasts and substack and uh
alternate sort of parallel institutions
yeah it's fascinating to think uh as
well about I guess soft cancellation so
had Ricky Schlott on who co-authored the
cancelling of the American mind with
Greg
lukanov and um she was talking about all
of the different ways that people kind
of get soft cancelled and it's it's just
not being invited to the end of your
party uh you know it's people sitting in
different locations to you I think she
went to maybe NYU Stern and um she was
hiding Jordan Peterson books under her
bed um you know like [__] Anne Frank
in the Attic that philosophical an Frank
um and she was saying that you know it's
there's lots of um sort of ideological
[__] tests she called them which I
thought was a really great name uh you
know what do you think about Ben Shapiro
you know just like [__] throw that
hand grenade into into the room and see
if anyone pipes up and or doesn't pipe
up that was something that I learned
when I was in grad school was does
anyone just remain silent and not say oh
he's so he's an evil right-wing whatever
right if they just kind of keep their
head down and don't say anything you
know I sort of oh I observed that
silence is compliance of whatever
silence is violence or yeah whatever it
is what about the um you had this
interesting idea about the hidden
hierarchies of the Harvard Extension
school thing yeah yeah well I saw that
with you know I was I was you know
observing what was occurring on Twitter
SLX with Christopher rufo who was one of
the sort of Architects of uh pointing
out and removing the the Harvard
Professor after her comments about you
know kind of condoning anti-Semitism on
campus and then discovering her
plagiarism and all this but you know a
after he you know he was perceived to be
successful I mean she was she was ousted
she was pressured to resign and she did
all of these professors at Elite
University ities and all of these you
know this you know University supporting
members of the chattering class were
saying oh Christopher rufo got a degree
from the Harvard Extension school and
you know did are people aware that
that's not the real Harvard and people
do people understand that that's not
typically what we think of as uh a real
Graduate Studies degree at a m it's not
a real master's degree from Harvard uh
and you know they they just wanted
people to be very aware that this you
know this this sort of Outsider this PL
who got this degree from this extension
school he's not a real academic he's not
a real serious thinker yeah he's written
books yes he works at a at a very
prominent Think Tank and yes he's like
very successful in the real world but he
has his degree for which is sort of
getting things backwards right you want
the degree um in order to signify that
you're capable in the real world but you
know they have the oh this guy's capable
in the real world but now they're
looking at the the the degree as if it's
it's somehow um it's fraudulent and
therefore this uh nullifies all of his
that's indicative of his real value
exactly yeah they're they're placing his
value on the the educational credential
rather than uh on his Effectiveness in
in his life and in his career so you
know I'm watching this and I'm thinking
like yeah this is exactly I mean I'm I'm
I've seen this you know since entering
College since entering higher ed this
strange status anxiety particularly
among people who attend these kind of
Institutions I mean the people who were
pointing this out about rufo's degree
were professors or graduates of whatever
Harvard or Oberlin or Stanford whatever
like these these of places people didn't
knew the language they understood what
an extension school was yes exactly and
and it's just amazing to me that Harvard
even has this program in the first place
because it relies on that duplicitous
game of uh you know if you're if you're
a what a member of the unwashed masses
and you go to the Harvard Extension
School website it actually says we are
Harvard you will have the Harvard degree
you can put it it even says something
like you'll have the you know you'll be
able to put Harvard on your resume this
is on the official website um while Sim
multaneously communicating the coded
message to everyone else at Harvard and
everyone else in this sort of rarified
segment of society that you know we have
to do that you know we have to put that
on the website but it's not really hard
you're not on the main stage you're kind
of on the second stage in the festival
it's like the Overflow room why would
like it's just it shocks me that they're
willing to take the reputational hit to
operate a degree Mill I mean to me it's
just very like tody like it's almost
like you know I have this maybe this
judgmental atttitude I like this is like
very kind of vulgar that you guys would
even do this in the first place that
you're playing this game and yeah I
thought it was very yeah very ugly the
way that they were they were pointing
this out about rufo and it also ended up
backfiring I think because they felt
this sort of this faction of cultural
Elites and these Legacy institutions
felt threatened they felt like they had
received an l and so they had to lash
out and get back at him well it's the
same as you know someone does something
to you a really cutting Jive and you're
like uh uh [__] shoes like it's just you
know it's the only thing
like [__] just gra at I remember once
there this guy so funny there this uh
dude stood in the front door of a
nightclub complaining about the fact
that he couldn't get in and he just kept
on chirping and kept on chirping and
kept on chirping and I was feeling
particularly pissy that day or whatever
so I said something back to him and I've
got like two or three 6'4 Jordy gorillas
either side of me that are working and
I'm busy trying to organize clipboards
or something else and he couldn't think
of anything to do so I had a a necklace
on of some kind like on the outside of a
T-shirt and he sort of reached forward
and like grab grabbed that and like that
was the one thing and then sort of
scuttled off and I bro like my 35 like
fashion neet necklace isn't a big deal
but just that that's the one thing and
it's kind of the same as Christopher
rufo like
wwww I extension school like it's not
you're not part of the real chattering
classes yeah yeah that's exact yeah it
was very like shortsighted and and
ultimately I think it was damaging to
them of oh anyone else that's got that
degree or is thinking about going to
that place is oh well they said that
ultimately when the rubber meets the
road Chris rufo is like just one of the
[__] like peasants the same as the
rest of us right so maybe I shouldn't
think about oh that's interest so you're
saying that that anyone who might want
to apply for the Harvard Extension
school will see that and so they'll have
fewer applicants you know the
institution will ultimately be less
profitable I didn't even think about
that part definitely less prestigious I
was I was thinking on the reputation end
of it rather than the sort of economic
end but yeah this this idea that um that
people will observe I mean I thought it
was an error for two reasons one was
that it was most people don't like snobs
right so they see this and they just
feel like icky about it that they're
even pointing this out in the first
place or that they think that they're
somehow Superior um they don't like that
attitude and then the second was that uh
it to me it kind of exposed the the
hollow of the egalitarian Dogma the
supposed egalitarian dogma of elite
Academia that you know oh we're all for
equity and you know Dei or whatever it
is that we're so accepting and tolerant
and welcoming uh but by the way like you
know your your aristocratic title is
fraudulent and you're a fake and you
know so you know I was texting a friend
earlier about this he's he's actually a
grad student at Harvard and I was like
my impression of this was basically like
the attitude at Elite universities is
everyone is equal but some people are
less equal than others right it's sort
of a spin on on the the uh the animal
farm idea we're all
you you had that George Orwell quote um
you said how in the road to Wigan piia
George Orwell's explaining how upper
class snobs while theoretically pining
for a classless society cling Like Glue
to their miserable fragments of social
Prestige I love that yeah I love that
line I mean the whole yeah the book is
great Orwell was so astute in his
analysis of class but that was just yeah
I mean this has been going on for you
know 100 years now and that was the
first thing that came to mind when I was
seeing this that you know these these
supposedly open-minded tolerant
welcoming people were suddenly pointing
out that he got a degree from from the
institution right like it's your website
you got over the you got over the bar
that everybody asked for but you kind of
landed in an awkward place on the crash
man yeah you know and yeah you're so
right it's this and this is why
fundamentally I think that people are so
skeptical and critical of anyone who
prizes about their morality or how
ethical or how caring they are publicly
you go what are you covering up for I
don't believe that you actually think
that and sure enough when the gloves are
off and you see someone in a little bit
of pressure or receiving a little bit of
heat where did they go well all of the
inclusivity and egalitarianism and care
for the beauty of Academia overall all
of that's out the window yeah yeah when
the pressure is on right when people
feel threatened when they feel in a
sense of sort of emotional intensity a
lot of negative emotion suddenly you
know the mask slips and you can see what
toys are out of the pram they're just as
and you know this is the concern that
people had all along yeah it's like oh
that's what we thought you were like we
thought that you were high futing not
actually caring adrenic com drinking L
hooded nose pentagram dancing like
[__] and sure enough your your mask
has slipped so I mean this you've got
your brand new book out which everyone
can go and buy right now that you're go
and buy this very second
we haven't ever spoken about this
because pretty much since I've known you
at some point you've been working on
your Memoir troubled yeah luxury beliefs
yeah that is a kind of example of luxury
belief although it's not patient zero
how do you explain to my audience that
hasn't yet heard you talk about a topic
that you've repop
poiz how do you explain luxury beliefs
right luxury beliefs are ideas and
opinions that confer status on the
affluent while often inflicting costs on
the lower classes and a core component
of a luxury belief is that the believer
is often sheltered from the consequences
of his or her belief um and you know we
can get into specific examples but yeah
I like this one that we've been sort of
touching on this snobbish attitude about
higher ed and how yeah so on the one
hand I mean you're when when people are
pointing out that this school or that
school is better than the other um you
are sort of boosting your own status
right especially these people who are
already graduates of or teaching at
these institutions they bolstering their
own status uh and then you know they by
by speaking in this way about the
hierarchies and you know which school is
actually above which other school they
are sort of inflicting costs on everyone
else who would like to ascend the
educational ladder who would like to get
a degree um but a lot of these people
just don't interact much with people who
uh are upwardly mobile or trying to be
upwardly mobile who are trying to go to
university trying to get a degree um the
vast majority and I and I talk about a
lot of the statistics in my book about
this in the later chapters about how
more than 80% of IV League graduates
have at least one parent who went to
University I mean that's they're sort of
immersed in it from birth they've never
actually interacted with a person or had
a 15-minute conversation with someone
who doesn't have a degree or on their
way to getting a degree uh and it's just
not on their radar and so in their world
you know everyone went to University or
everyone should go or you know anyone
who did doesn't go to the same category
of University that they went to there's
something wrong with them and I noticed
this a lot uh when when I arrived on
campus I mean and it's very subtle I
mean at first I was sort of you know to
some degree I think I was duped because
I fell for the oh everyone's equal
everyone's fine everyone and you know
also the other thing about these these
institutions now is that they don't they
don't look the same right one of the the
ideas about or one of the components of
the luxury belief idea is that luxury
beliefs have to a large extent replaced
luxury goods uh which isn't to say that
luxury goods don't still signify status
brand names and all of those things
still matter but my claim is that that
luxury goods have become a noisier
signal of status you can't tell right
away necessarily anymore when you just
go about your life in public who's rich
and who's poor just by how they look um
and so you know I build on these sort of
sociological Frameworks uh in my writing
and my book um work from Thorston Vin at
the turn of the 20th century he wrote
The Theory of the Leisure Class he wrote
about how you know the upper class the
aristocrats of his time uh they
demonstrated their status through you
know Tuxedos and evening gowns and
pocket watches and monal and uh
expensive and intricate hobbies and uh
attending lavish events uh hiring
servants those kinds of things and then
by the mid 20th century there was a
sociologist named Pierre bordeu who
wrote a book called distinction a social
critique of the Judgment of taste uh and
one of his insights in that book was
that
um rich people affluent people they'll
convert their economic capital into
cultural capital uh and so they'll spend
money money in order to demonstrate
their class or exhibit their membership
into this rarified Strat of society and
so in his day you know again in the mid-
20th century and he was mostly
commenting on French culture but people
can sort of understand what you know
what he's getting at where people would
spend spend money to uh learn about the
subtleties of wine or the intricacies of
art or uh fashion yeah falconry or or
beagling or golf or these kinds of you
know that you have to have money you
can't uh be the kind of person who works
Emanual job or who you
know yeah soft you see the same thing in
almost uh the reverse in Asian societies
at the moment when I went to Thailand
for the first time all of the
receptionists were wearing lighter
makeup on their face and I thought to
myself why cuz it's so silly because the
you know the face finishes on whatever
the jawline here and you know the
blending between the face and the neck
is difficult to do and I thought why and
I asked someone why the [__] are they
like face making their faces pale at and
they said oh well it's because the
indigent laborers the people that work
out in the fields are heavily tanned so
the higher class jobs are the ones that
are inside which means that the paler
you are the more status you is conferred
on you by your profession but then I
also realized how stupid of me and how
you know myopically Western of me to do
that coming from Newcastle upon time the
Jersey Shore of the UK where girls turn
themselves orange to signify I have all
of this leisure time I'm able to go away
on holiday to exotic places and by the
beach and get sun on me I like that yeah
yeah that's very interesting yeah yeah
so if you if you live in like northern
Europe or somewhere cold where there
isn't a lot of sun having a tan is the
the signifier status so yeah I think
yeah that's that's an important Point
here that you know it it does vary from
culture to culture I mean I point you
know I point this out the research and
everything in my writing about how
status itself the specific examples and
manifestations can be ephemeral they can
be they can vary by time and place and
culture and generation and so on but the
desire for status the desire to exhibit
it to show other people how prestigious
or how dominant or how um you know how
important you are that that remains and
so my my claim is that luxury beliefs I
mean they're mostly confined to that
sort of Highly Educated people who
attend the universities people who study
there people who are graduates of these
places uh who tend to operate uh Legacy
institutions who run uh media and and
and Academia and who generate
people who work in sort of culturally
influential um organizations and a lot
of them hold these luxury beliefs I
think we saw this uh in 2020 and 2021
with the defund the police movement I
mean I coined the term luxury beliefs in
2019 and started uh to to write about it
and do the research to sort of support
this idea and point everything out that
um uh sort of all of all of the the the
the sociological concepts under ging it
and then the like 6 months later people
started talking about defunding the
police I was like I don't even have to
like I felt like I didn't even have to
like you know here's the reasoning
behind luxury belief is just defund the
police like it's right there you don't
even have to it's the most whenever
somebody brings up your work to me and
talks about luxury beliefs the patient
zero example is defund the police yeah
because it's so intuitive of course can
you explain why that encapsulates luxury
beliefs s of structurally or
functionally so well yeah yeah so so
yeah the luxury beliefs idea if you say
defund the police you are increasing
your own status because I mean you look
like a caring person you look
open-minded and interesting and and uh
and highly educated um and so and it
also signifies that you're the kind of
person who went to certain kinds of
schools you consume certain kinds of
media you listen to certain kinds of
podcasts and so on um and so it makes
you look a certain way to your peers but
once the support for defund the police
becomes implemented into policy once
police stations and police departments
uh have reduced funding once you
cultivate an attitude so it's not just
the policy but you're also cultivating
the culture and the attitude around law
enforcement that oh we don't need police
uh you sort of give permission to people
to be suspicious of police or to be
derogatory towards police um as a result
we saw that a lot of a lot of police
officers started retiring in large
numbers uh there's reports in in major
US cities that they're having difficulty
with recruitment because if you're smart
capable young person who wants to make a
difference in your community like why
would you want that job uh if you know
that people are going to view you with
suspicion or with some kind of you know
that that you're sort of malicious or or
evil I mean cops I mean they get paid
okay but it's not like uh considering
the the potential danger they face in
their job part of the reason why people
would want to do it is because cops
formerly used to be seen as respectable
and and and admirable and people convert
a lot of status onto them well think
about the difference between when a
policeman currently in in the sort of
current defund the police era that we're
in policeman turns up at the scene
versus a firefighter or an ambulance A&E
person you know the other two emergency
services are seen heralded as Heroes
yeah and the police like is it aab mhm
aab or all cops are bastards forgot
about that yeah yeah yeah and and so who
wants that job and so gradually and saw
this uh in the aftermath of the defund
the police movement that violent crime
spiked all across the US especially
major cities uh homicide rates increased
to levels not seen since the early 1990s
um and so when all of this was unfolding
I actually I tried to find some survey
data to see like who's actually you know
like because I don't know anyone in my
personal life who thinks that we should
defund the police I mean other than you
know some some people at C Cambridge and
other Elite universities but ordinary
people who are outside of these
institutions I didn't know anyone who
was supporting this movement so I had a
suspicion this was you know actually a
legitimate luxury belief I looked at
survey data for it um found one in yugov
in 2020 which found that they they
collected data from a representative
sample of Americans and they broke down
the data by income category and it was
the highest income Americans who were
the most supportive of defunding the
police and it was the lowest income
Americans who were the least supportive
uh and then when when um later there the
different different uh findings were uh
reported for major US cities like
Minneapolis and Detroit uh one in New
York City uh they found that white
Democrats were far more supportive of
defunding the police than Black and
Hispanic Democrats and so it was like
the the the people who were supposedly
uh so so kind and so uh sympathetic
towards uh the marginalized and the
dispossessed and the poor and so on they
were supporting something that actually
those groups didn't even want and I mean
an increased number of them were being
victimized as a result of it um in my
book I point out that uh if you compare
the lowest income Americans to Americans
who earn the median income there's what
is it they're two to three times more
likely to be victims of of violent uh
crimes they're uh seven times more
likely to be victims of assault they're
20 times more likely to be victims of
sexual assault like essentially across
the board the lower your income the more
likely you are to be a target of crime
could do with the police yes exactly you
could yeah it would be nice have someone
you could call if you're being
burglarized or or assaulted um and so
yeah it was a it was a complete uh uh
sort of backfiring and I haven't seen
you know there hasn't really been any
sort of accountability or any kind of um
acknowledgement of what happened in the
aftermath of that movement yeah it's
wild and then obviously the the big
elephant in the room here is that the
people who were supporting it are the
ones who are the most likely to live in
a gated community in an area or a
neighborhood that has not called the
police in a decade since the last time
that someone from the community that
they're probably talking about trying to
protect accidentally wandered through
their gated community uh so it's rules
for thee but not for me and let me
explain to you poor underclass peasant
person what is best for you from my
vantage point out here in my very
comfortable home yes yes yeah yeah so
that's yeah that's one of the components
of the luxury Bel is that the believer
is sheltered from the consequences of
the belief and so yeah the people who
were supporting the defund the police
movement uh largely college educated
living in safe communities living in
gated communities there were reports um
during the the political unrest in 2020
and all of the BLM demonstrations and so
on all of the riots that people in sh
like rich people in Chicago were hiring
private security to patrol their
neighborhoods because you know the
police were either distracted due to all
of the uh social unrest and crime that
was occurring uh or because police were
retiring and so on and so they were
hiring Private Security in these um rich
neighborhoods and then in New York City
there were reports of people just
fleeing to The Hamptons like you know if
you have money and you have resources
you can just flee to your private little
gated area and from home start tweeting
about defund the police and get all the
likes and plot it my God you're so
caring I know the cops are so wrong like
they're treating these poor black people
so badly and you can I mean I think
people who are um sort of affluent upper
middle class people they have a mistaken
view of what sort of Poverty Looks like
their only exposure to it is when they
see um when when they see it reported in
the media when it's a criminal who's
committed some kind of uh transgression
and that surfaces up and then they learn
about the criminals backstory and they
start to feel sympathetic and so on and
so forth and there's not nearly as much
time spent on the victims of that
person's crime and so in and often what
happens is that in in at at least the
the imagination of this Strat of society
that you know they conflate poverty with
criminality and the reason why someone
commits crimes is because they're poor
without really digging into the data or
the research and understanding that the
vast majority of poor people never
commit any crimes they're more they're
far more likely to be victims of crime
than a perpetrator and they don't really
think about this and then through the
sort of portrayal of poverty I think in
pop culture is kind of mistaken too at
least in more sort of recent media where
you know very few TV shows it's just not
exciting to see some workingclass person
making you know minimum wage going to
work clocking in clocking out going home
to their family and living a normal life
but it's more interesting to see you
know the the struggling school teacher
who decides to break bad and start
cooking meth and lashing out at the
system and that's just a much more
interesting story uh and so that is I
mean there was this movie that came out
I think it was last year the year before
Emily the criminal with Aubrey Plaza I
don't know if you saw it but it was I
mean it was like the perfect kind of
movie for this for this you know the
luxury belief class it's this young
woman who works in food catering and she
has this [__] boss and she has dream
I think she she is a college graduate
she has dreams of being an artist but
she has difficulty monetizing her
artwork and so she caters food but then
she like gets hooked in with this gang
and like learns how to shoplift and you
know the whole thing is like you know
well you know Screw the system you know
I can't make money off my artwork and I
have to work in food catering and this
is just ridiculous and so I'm going to
you know start stealing and and robbing
people and and the movie is portraying
this as like a perfectly reasonable
course of action right and uh this is
like it's basically like Breaking Bad
but the young woman version for yeah
yeah and uh yeah I just think it's uh
that's that's part of what drives the
luxury beliefs
phenomenon yeah it's wild man and when
you see that you you really can't unse
see it uh Mary Harrington had this about
a lot of the advances that were proposed
by the feminist movement in the 50s 60s
s and 70s were um put forward by women
For Whom the impact wouldn't affect them
so a perfect example is I guess the push
toward Independence and uh the
derogation of chivalry by men because
chivalry in some ways can be patronizing
must be patronizing to women like I can
open the door for myself right I can
carry my own bags right like I can pull
my own share out I can pay for my own
dinner and in a world where women are
trying to find and establish themselves
socioeconomically as independent agents
aside from the husband or partner that
they're supposed to need I can
understand why that would be the case
but as she said it is a direct line from
men shouldn't open the door and don't
need to to why you shouldn't hit your
wife right because the consensus is
women are more fragile vulnerable and
need to be protected and men should be
the ones that do that protecting and
it's the women who are married to men
who had a two- parent household old who
had a relatively good example of how to
treat women when they were growing up
who have been through all of the
institutions that have kind of softly
embedded what chivalry is in any case
because that's just the way that a a
more sophisticated social life goes MH
but that doesn't think about women who
are in an underclass or workingclass
environment who are in a relationship
with a guy who never knew his father
whose mom was cycling in and out of
different boyfriends or Partners or
whatever in the house who was maybe
abused used physically or verbally or
emotionally or whatever while they were
growing up all of whom's friends are
Ruffians that are going about and
antisocial behavior and all of this
stuff and it's like well I know that for
you lady that drives a Mercedes-Benz you
might like the idea of being liberated
from men holding the door open for you
but Downstream from that you've also
liberated women from being protected
from their underclass partner from
hitting them when he gets annoyed on a
nighttime and uh I really I just thought
that that was such an interesting frame
the same thing goes for uh support for
um abortion rights right when you think
about that is I think that it is skewed
toward the people in the upper class
believe that it is a great idea to
restrict abortion rights overall to give
less access but you think well maybe if
you were
woman 213 of one particular Village
somewhere who's six kids deep yeah to
three different men maybe easy access to
birth control would be a good thing for
them to have and uh yeah it's just it's
so interesting how it can be split up by
race or it can be split up by class or
it can be split up within gender yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's yeah that was I mean
it's it's interesting because I think
that a lot of the people who promote
these views or who think that these are
sort of progressive or fashionable or
enlightened they don't think about how
it would affect someone outside of their
social strata or they mistakenly
overextend the way that they think to
everyone else that well here's what
would be good for me or here's what
would be good for my class or my group
and therefore it would be good for
everyone or the only reason why other
people aren't thinking like me or aren't
pursuing the same kind of life as me is
because they don't have the same uh or
or because my preferences aren't aren't
implemented in society or throughout
culture I mean that yeah what you said
earlier about about Mary Harrington's
point is interesting I mean I I saw this
firsthand that where I grew up basically
anyone anyone like you know uh who was
remotely sort of academically inclined
you know went off to some State
University everyone who who wasn't but
still had some sort of uh restlessness
or ambition they joined the military and
then all the guys who were left behind I
mean there's there's you know not not
much left for the women there to to pick
from and a lot of these guys did grow up
without dads or without good sort of
male role models around and yeah I mean
yeah what ends up happening often is
like you know women get imp you know
they have children with multiple men or
the men uh you know they they have
multiple partners and don't interact
with their kids I mean I you know I now
have friends that I graduated from high
school with who are these guys and yeah
it's just it looks very different right
like that um the sort of Liberation and
the belief that you know women don't
need a man or men shouldn't uh you know
women can live the same kind of Life as
a man and maybe it's true if you are
affluent and you go off to college and
you're going to be a young professional
uh career-driven person fig is but if
you're just working a menial job and
you're not I mean most people aren't
going to derive a ton of satisfaction
from the way that they make money well
there's a story that you I remember you
telling me maybe about some lady friend
that you'd spoken to about she said that
we should be able to move beyond the
nuclear family because it's restrictive
and constraining yeah yeah this was um
someone I graduated from Yale with we
were somehow got on the topic of family
and future and this kind of thing and
she was basically telling me that yeah
marriage is this outdated patriarchal
institution and we should Society should
move Beyond it we should evolve get past
it and so I asked her well how did you
grow up what was your like family life
situation when you were a child and she
said you know I was raised by my mom and
my dad and you know I did have that kind
of you know conventional family and then
I asked her what she planned to do later
in her you know once you know cuz she
was planning to she was working at a
technology firm she was going to go to
law school but I asked her in her future
when she has a family or if she wanted a
family what would she do and she said oh
yeah you know I do want a family someday
and I'll probably get married and have a
husband and you know essentially get
married and like you know partake in
this outdated patriarchal institution
and so I was thinking that okay you
benefited from this uh age-old ancient
sort of patriarchal but you know this
institution and you plan to carry the
benefits of that uh Arrangement forward
for your own children but your official
public position is no one should do this
it's outdated she was sort of
denigrating it trying to downplay it
saying other people shouldn't do this
and to me it seemed very duplicitous
that you know this clearly marriage has
positive benefits I mean that was
something that I learned when I got to
college was almost every single one of
my classmates and peers came from two
parent families whereas where I grew up
it was basically zero and so clearly
marriage had some you know some kind of
effect here um and yet the place the the
the the group that is the most likely to
downplay the benefits of marriage are
the most likely to be products of
successful marriages under are the most
likely to form marriages
themselves how come you're not more
bitter about your
childhood uh I mean I I used to be I
used to actually be more Angry uh when I
was in my late teens early 20s um
I mean I think part of it was just
getting older um I think just age you
just things just kind of tend to like
burn out and dim over time anyway
um and I think you know the other was
just a lot of sort of self uh focused
work uh self
improvement um trying to you know get
past it and put it all into context
and realize you know that that on the
one hand people are of responsible for
they do in their lives um but on the
other I mean to understand the sort
of to understand the genealogy of the
ideas that led us to this point that's
been helpful too to understand that yes
like dayto day we have agency over our
lives but the sort of there are these
decisions and and cultural trajectories
and all of these other forces that are
in place that that play a role too and
so you know when I start to dig to at
the root of this of you know who is
responsible for some of these ideas who
uh promotes the luxury beliefs and so on
and entering into institutions where I
can see it you know I can it helps me to
just understand it and I think that sort
of settles my you know settles my anger
a bit
too it's very interesting thinking about
that I I had a s chaver on she's a
psychotherapist pushing back very hard
against what she calls Instagram therapy
which is identifying everybody as victim
and that they've got trauma and stuff
and she said
um remembering that you experiened
trauma isn't being a victim making your
identity out of it is yeah yeah yeah I
think that's well put I mean I didn't
really I didn't really think of myself
as a victim and and people didn't call
me a victim I never thought on those
terms until I got to college before that
it was just day-to-day life I mean it
was just you know trying to struggling
to get by trying to make money trying to
whatever living paycheck to paycheck and
then later joining the military and you
know just my my uh plate was full later
um you know sort of towards the end of
my enlistment before I entered College I
did um do a stint in in rehab and I
talked to uh therapists and you know I
did sort of address a lot of the issues
that I had experienced when I was a kid
and that was helpful too I think to just
sort of contextualize it and also to um
I know just sort of be more open with
the people I grew up with and close with
you know my sister and my mom and all
these people to just you my adopted
family to to talk to them about all of
this I mean that's helpful too I think
there is this
um this tendency for young people young
men in particular that you know
self-sufficiency will solve all your
problems to just be completely
self-reliant you don't have to rely on
anyone you know your your relationships
are sort of
peripheral um and I Liv that way for a
while and it probably did help um to
sort of I don't know led me to equip
myself to be you know a self-sufficient
person but later you know I did realize
that actually relationships are
important I mean I went through I think
the first six years um after I left home
I never visited um I never visited for
the holidays I never visited for for any
kind of special occasions I mean I did
visit like you know on and off whenever
you know really whenever it suited my
schedule I was very selfish um but then
later you know now I make an effort now
I make an effort to do all those things
and um realize that actually you know
all of these things relationships are
more important than than you think
especially when you're young right there
there is uh there's value there um even
if you think there isn't yeah there's a
degree of Romanticism about monk mode
and lone rangering it uh and I think my
current theory on this is that monk mode
is a great tool but a bad Master H
because if you continue to pray at the
altar of it over a long enough amount of
time the reason that you're doing some
equivalent of Monk mode right which is
uh a overreliance on self-sufficiency
introspection and isolation so that you
can focus on making yourself into a
better version of you because quite
rightly there are a lot of distractions
out there in the world and if you're
trying to do a ton of self-work or you
going to therapy or you're in rehab
you're probably not going to have the
most flourishing social life it's going
to be difficult for you to juggle all of
these plates and if you do try and
juggle all of the plates you're going to
restrict your progress in that area like
committing yourself to one thing or a
very narrow band of things is more than
it's not additive it's multiplicative
right it allows you to Triple down
quadruple down all of your efforts into
one very tight area and I found myself
toward the end of my 20s through my
manop pause that I I really really
enjoyed monk mode but I saw especially
for someone that has introverted
Tendencies and I get my energy mostly
from being on my own a lot of the time
that it started to become more alluring
to me than being back out into the world
but the problem with that is the reason
that you're doing the monk mode thing or
the rehab thing or whatever is to form
yourself into a functional member of
society who can then go and reintegrate
and that's the problem that the progress
can become addictive to the point where
it stops you from doing the thing you're
like the thing that you're doing is
sacrificing the thing that you are doing
it in order to get yeah yes yeah yeah
yeah you sort of mistake the the means
for the end the end goal you're sort of
yeah yeah it's um and I think it's
difficult to to keep in mind I think a
lot of people have difficulty with that
especially when you're young you like
what what are your actions attempting to
accomplish what's your overarching goal
um you know Robert Green makes that
distinction between tactician versus
strategist right the tactician is just
what's directly in front of you what do
you need to do next and the strategist
is well what's all of this for like what
are each of those steps trying to get
you to and I think yeah when you're
young you just think oh I want to make
money and like money becomes the thing
and it's like well what's the money for
like what do you want to do with that
money when you build up your bank
account what is that the goal is just to
have a big number uh on your uh balance
or is it to take care of your loved ones
to have the freedom to be able to
interact with people that you care about
and to provide and those kinds of things
and I I think I I mean I kind of came to
that realization when I was in my mid
20s but it wasn't until my later 20s
really probably right not until I was
about to start grad school I was was
like 20 28 but I really had that
realization that oh the reason why I'm
working so hard and trying to get
educated and successful and trying to
make money and all these things is so
that I could take care of my my current
family My adoptive family but then also
for if and when I have a family later
we'll say when that um I'll be able to
take care of them too in a way that I
lacked when I was a kid um and that's
what ultimately all of these things are
for it's not just to whatever increase
the the numbers on on my you know social
media or on my balance or something like
that so your background the life that
you went
through to where you ended up
uh Air Force yeah Air Force Air Force US
Air Force GI Bill
Yale
Cambridge PhD book you know going to be
an amazing selling book all the rest of
the stuff what do you attribute that
trajectory to given that you're friends
with so many of the people that you grew
up with that are still they're the guy
they're that guy with three baby mamas
and a bunch of alimony or whatever and
they're in the same town in the same
whatever what was formative or what what
do you attribute the change in you to
that the other people didn't I mean
there are probably you know there's a
variety of factors I think one is
um you know you you do need to have like
a a certain amount of like innate drive
or ambition in the first place and that
I I'm not entirely sure you can you can
you can drill that into people um so you
have to have that sort of raw material
in the first place but one point that I
try to make in the book is that things
could have very easily gone a different
direction um I think having sort of
aptitude and drive and ambition those
are necessary but not sufficient that
there are a lot of guys I think who are
sort of smart and talented and ambitious
but they're just surrounded by chaos and
disorder and you know lack opportunity
or or they've just been sort of beaten
down by life so much that they don't
even think to like spot the
opportunities that are around you um and
capitalize on them and so so that was
there so I think some of the raw
material was probably there um and then
the other thing was just uh making this
you know kind of halfway impulsive
decision when I was 17 to just enlist
and get out of my hometown and I kind of
knew that you know I at this point you
know I I'd had two jobs when I was in
high school I was a dishwasher at a
restaurant and then I was a bag boy at a
grocery store and I kind of looked
around at my co-workers who were a
little older than me these were guys you
know this kind of guy in their early to
mid 20s you know maybe they like some of
them like they were like 24 but had a
girlfriend in high school and they were
just like kind of creepy weird Stoner
guy or the guy who you know would ride a
dirt bike and you know just like smoke a
lot of weed in the parking lot and just
you know kind of aimless in a drift and
I thought like I I think now when you're
17 or 18 that's kind of cool to live
that life but when you're 24 or 28 like
that's kind of pathetic and even when I
was a teenager I had that thought that
you know sometimes my friends and I
would ask these guys to like get us beer
hook us up with weed or whatever and you
know some part of me I was I was like
happy they were doing it but on the
other hand I was like why are you doing
this for us man like what kind of loser
is hanging out with a bunch of high
schoolers and I don't want to be like
the weird old guy at the high school
party when I'm that age um and so you
know a variety of factors led me to uh
just enlist right away I barely
graduated high school I mean I I was
smart and that that's the other point
that I I try to make in the book is that
a lot of people want to blame the school
system or that there's something wrong
with teachers or we aren't paying them
enough and and maybe some of those
things are true but teachers aren't dumb
like that most teachers get into that
profession because they care about kids
and they want them to do well and
they're usually pretty observant about
like which kids are sort of curious and
academically inclined and my teachers
could see that in me but I just had no
motivation or desire to do well in
school it just wasn't there for me um
and so my teachers were just you know uh
continually frustrated by me and so yeah
I enlist I get out of there basic
training I get stationed I spend some
time overseas and sort of have that
structure uh around me uh a couple days
ago I spoke with a a mutual friend of
ours pulina Pomano and she asked me this
question of when I read your book and I
read about what you were like when you
were a teenager when you were in high
school and then I meet you now like it
just doesn't like there's a disconnect I
don't understand it and I explained that
I was in the Air Force for8 years like
that's a long time like I was in from 17
to 25
and you know the book I kind of like
gloss over because it's it's kind of
mind-numbing and boring but it's like
you know make your bed you know like
make sure your uniform is you know
perfect and like every Pete is in boot
camp exactly it it is kind of like that
especially for the first six months to a
year when you're in training it's like
you're not a you're not a person you're
just like a cog in this machine of just
like you know what like cleaning and and
and and being meticulous about every
little aspect of your existence um and I
hated it I hated every second of
but it was it was important for me to go
through that uh to like learn the skills
that I kind of lacked when I was growing
up of just like here's how to be an
adult here's how to take care of
yourself here's how to dress properly
and like even basic things right what
were the most surprising I I think this
would be a nice framing
actually As you move up through the
kakaa sphere of different social strata
what were the most surprising
realizations going from Rob 1.0 to Rob
2.0 which is I guess from teenager to uh
being in the Air Force what were the
things where you're like oh my God like
that's a an expectation or a social
convention or that's a way of operating
or it's a belief or whatever I mean I
think probably one of the bigger ones
was um like learning the distinction
between like self-discipline and
motivation uh because I I lacked I
really lacked both when I was a
teenager um you know I didn't feel MO at
to do well but I also had I had no
external discipline around me really I
mean I had it in sort of fits and starts
in different periods it was just a very
sort of chaotic early life but I had no
self-discipline certainly like I
couldn't impose on myself it just you
know I didn't I didn't have the the
tools to do that but then in the
military I learned it that you know at
first it was imposed from on high that
this is how you will do things and then
it gets drilled into you and then you
just learn on your own like oh this is
how you get things done is motivation is
you know so the the distinction the
motiv is just a feeling it's like do I
want to do this or not and if I don't
want to do it I lack the motivation and
I'm just not going to do it whereas
self-discipline is I'm going to do this
regardless of how I feel uh and so you
know for for some people it may make
sense in in the context of like going to
the gym that I don't feel like going to
the gym today but self-discipline is it
doesn't matter how you feel like oh you
have a feeling who cares like what are
your actions what are you actually going
to do now ignore those feelings and and
do what you've set out to do and so it
was like that for my work for things
like I mean even showing up to work on
time um I mean it's it's kind of sad but
I was one of the better workers uh at my
jobs in high school and even then I was
like not on time half the time like it
didn't matter I didn't feel like it and
then the military was if you don't show
up to work on time you get Court Marshal
and you go to military prison like
that's the life and once I learned like
to to operate by those standards and
those regulations those policies that it
dawned on me that actually you know Joo
has this phrase discipline equals
Freedom that once you sort of Outsource
all of your decisions to this sort of
regimented system then suddenly like
life gets better and you do have more
freedom you have the freedom to think
about other things or to uh direct your
attention to certain projects or goals
or ideas and you don't have to live your
life in this constant state of chaos of
oh I don't have any money now what you
know like that you just you know set the
set set the system so that your money
goes here and this is what you're going
to do when you go to work at this time
and this is when you leave and this is
what's and having that regimented system
was really uh important for me and now I
just you know I do it it's second nature
to me but it took eight years to get
there so yeah I think those those those
kinds of things discipline was the big
one what do people who didn't grow up in
poverty not know about what it's like to
grow up in
poverty um I mean I think I think
poverty poverty
is it's an
interesting
question because I think a lot of people
actually attempt
to they attempt to imagine it I I know a
lot of people actually who didn't grow
up poor but who at least try to imagine
what it would have been like to be poor
um and I think like the the imagination
probably isn't too far off from the
reality that there are certain things
that you want but maybe you can't get or
if you want a a toy or certain food or a
certain thing that you know I think
poverty now for at least in sort of
developed First World countries very few
people are actually Starving in the
street but it's more like you know I I
want to get um you know maybe it's like
a special occasion and I want to rent a
video game at Blockbuster but that's $6
and we're only going to let you rent a
movie because it's $3 like those kinds
of like weird Small Things um and you
can only go on a special occasion for
your birthday or something it's not like
a weekly uh currence um the other thing
is like the I think like the
the social environment is something
people don't think about as well that
what family life and communities look
like in poor and working-class areas now
are much different
than than they than they used to look
like I mean I cite this statistic in my
book about
how in the 1960s 95% of children in the
US regardless of social class were
raised by both of their birth parents
and then by 2005 for the upper class it
had dropped to 85% so there was a slight
dip but by and large that's the norm
still whereas for workingclass families
in the US working-class children um it
dropped from 95% to 30% and that was
2005 my guess is it's dropped a little
bit further than that now um and so just
to give a sort of a glimpse into this I
mean there was I had five close friends
growing up in high school and so there
was me sort of raised in foster homes
and adopted but there there were
divorces and other kinds of drama uh I
had two friends raised by single moms uh
one friend raised by a single dad I had
another friend who was raised by his
grandma because his dad was in prison
and his mom was addicted drugs and
that's kind of like the normal situation
when you go to like a if you go to a
high school in one of these areas and
just start asking people about their
parents or their families they'll start
describing about Dad's in prison or
mom's in drugs or you know I'm staying
with my aunt right now because my mom is
in rehab or whatever chaotic
yeah it's just total yeah it's just
totally chaotic and disorderly and this
is um that a point that I've made in my
writing is that you know childhood
poverty is not and again this is in the
context of the US and you know First
World countries that childhood poverty
is not really very strong predictor of
harmful or detrimental outcomes later in
life um the correlation is either very
weak or not significant at all between
growing a poor and growing up to uh
commit crimes or self-defeating
behaviors harm violence um drug
addiction unemployment all of these
kinds of social pathologies there's a
very sort of tenuous connection there
but for childhood instability and those
uh undesirable outcomes there's a strong
and consistent uh correlation there uh
and so childhood and stability is
measured by things like uh you know were
you raised by both of your birth par
parents was there a divorce how many
different adults moved in and out of
your home how frequently did you
relocate um basically how much
day-to-day disorder was there in your
life how much uncertainty was there and
that actually does seem to have a very
strong effect on the on childhood
development on their expectations on
their goals for themselves and and
what's interesting is that when
researchers control for childhood family
income the link remains remains strong
it remain significant between
instability and outcomes and so one way
to think about about this is um you know
if if there's a rich family um but
there's a lot of drama and chaos and
divorce and addiction and domestic
issues uh a child raised in that
environment is much more likely to have
detrimental outcomes more likely to
commit crimes or become addicted to
substances or
um uh or just yeah have have issues CH
you know children out of wedlock or
multiple with multiple partners versus
uh a child who is raised by two very
low-income parents who are married who
uh are very focused on creating a stable
and secure life for their kids and you
can kind of see this I think with like
immigrant families and low-income
families that uh haven't really been
quite uh afflicted by a lot of the
pathologies that have occurred in in the
US um and so I think that's important to
remember too it's that yes there's this
poverty component but there's also just
this kind of sometimes I wonder if
poverty is even the right word for the
way that I grew up I think squalor is
probably a more accurate term is like
yeah there was a bit of that material
impoverishment it was more just people
like living in a very um kind of ugly
and almost like masochistic way of just
you know uh careless and uh impulsive
and you know sort of drug adult what's
the mechanism that you think is causing
that to happen what is it about it's so
Universal that this uh unstable
disorganized upbringing regard
of class or material wealth M seems to
have such negative impact predictively
down what what do you think's the
mechanism though I mean you know I
probably some of it uh would be genetics
but I'm not sold that it's people that
people that are uh quick to anger
externalizing Behavior as parents give
the raw materials of externalizing
behavior to kids right okay I think I
think that's a like one one piece of it
but I think that Robert Clan reign
supreme
exactly um and I think yeah that that
would be the Robert pman answer um you
know and but I I I do think that that
that can't explain 100% of it because
you know if you if you just so for
example if you just look at white
Americans over time like all of the same
things have occurred across social
classes that actually you know 50 60
years ago um I mean like I'll give you
an example just for my adopted family so
um my adopted family are basically white
working-class people um on my mother's
side and so my
grandparents uh you know they were ra
you know they they grew up basically
during the Great Depression and they got
you know they got married you know my my
grandfather and my grand they would tell
me this story about how my grandfather
asked my grandmother to marry him and I
think he was 18 or 19 and she was like
17 and she you know they were just like
two the only two young people in this
town and you know and she was like I'll
marry you but you have to what is it you
have to stop smoking stop drinking stop
gambling and he was like done and done
they got married and they had a 60 plus
sex yes exactly well they yeah and then
they had how many I think they had four
or five kids yeah they had four kids
yeah and um and they were uh married for
60 plus years no issues you I'm sure
they had issues but like you know what I
mean and then they had four kids all
four kids divorced um and you know I
just you know they they had Mar they did
get married but then they ended up
getting divorced you know some of them
had you know kids step kids that kind of
thing now I'm a member of the Next
Generation and I'm seeing my cousins and
it's like it's not even marriage it's
just like oh like they hooked up and had
a kid but he hasn't spoken to his kid in
you know three years and you know so
that's what it looks like now and I
don't think the genetics in this family
lineage changed much it was the social
environment it's the incentives it's the
denigration of marriage it's um and I
don't even you know people will point to
economic factors but my grandparents
were very they were probably poorer than
they're definitely poor than my cousins
now you know like they could not afford
the things that my same-aged you know
30-year-old cousins could afford um so
it wasn't an economic issue I think a
lot of it was just cultural uh what are
your expectations I think a lot of it
has to do with a lot of the stuff that
you and I have talked about and you
speak about on your podcast around
incentives around sex and romance and
dating and just um yeah uh in the 19
what is it the 1940s 1950s my
grandparents generation it was like you
know if you wanted to have sex you had
to like live kind of life exactly and
that was uh that was just the reality
then and now it's um it's completely
different and I've presented this
thought experiment before I think I
posted this on on back when it was still
called Twitter which was if you traveled
back to
1945 just got in a time machine and
walked out in you know the post-war era
and you said in you know very soon I
think it was 1960 when the birth control
pill was invented you say very soon
there's going to be this magical
technology the birth control pill um so
contraceptives will be widely available
abortion will be you know it'll be more
accessible certainly than it is now um
so you'll have you know the all of these
reproductive options before
you do you think in the future there
will be more children born out of
wedlock or fewer do you think that there
will be more abortions or fewer do you
think there will be more children raised
in foster homes or orphanages living in
chaos and squalor more or less and I
think you know almost everyone that you
speak to in 1945 you present this survey
um I think almost every one of them
would say less they would say fewer and
then you know I but that's not the case
it was very much the opposite of that
that I think even these Technologies and
you know and and the culture and
everything sort of went in a in a very
different direction than I think people
had predicted Mary E came on the show
and
uh Adam and Eve and the pill Revisited a
new version of her old book mhm
fantastic just so great and it's true
man like you know we look back and it's
kind of cool in the red pill manosphere
even in the EP world you know the social
psychology world for people to almost
laugh snigger at how
rudimentary
the thinking was in the 1960s that
introducing birth control would result
in better outcomes in terms of abortion
better outcomes in terms of out out of
loock births uh but who then would have
been able to predict that that was what
was going to happen you're talking like
a fourth order effect right okay so
you're going to decrease shotgun
weddings because the onus is going to go
from the male that accidentally
impregnated to the woman who quote
unquote chose right it went from a man's
mistake to a woman's option and you go
okay right and then and then what's
going to happen to that and what's going
to happen to that but it's like a it's
so far down the line uh I was talking to
Scott Galloway h and uh you know he was
talking about the predictive power of
stuff in the past and he was saying you
know he'd looked through combed through
some research about the Great Depression
and had looked for anybody anyone
predict this it's like the year before
the Great Depression in the 20s no one
nothing not not a Cassandra in sight and
yet in retrospect you go how could no
one have seen this coming you know
hindsight hindsight is a wonderful thing
with regards to that one one question
I've got I think is kind of interesting
is so squala your word uh up until the
age of 16 17 17 up until the age of
17 that should set a pretty low honic
threshold right that uh you're in a nice
air conditioned room and your jeans fit
and don't have holes in and you're not
worrying about whether or not you can
pay for the Uber to get from here to the
airport how have you found your ability
to um honic adapt over time like can you
recall that as an anchor for your
quality of life or does it almost seem
like it's someone else that lived that
that's oh that's an interesting question
um I I guess it's it's a bit of both I
mean it's so day-to-day I think I don't
really yeah I don't really reflect in
that way you know you just sort of live
your life but when I reflect back and
when I think about it and I realize you
know there are those moments where like
wow like I can do this thing that
couldn't have done you know even even
after I was in the I mean I think it's
the pay structure has probably changed a
bit but when I enlisted in 2007 I was
you know I think the the I was making
like $1,200 a month was the the pay and
so I couldn't afford a belt you know
like it was like small little things
like that like you know once I cover you
know CU I moved yeah once I moved off
base I got this house with my friends
but you know you have to pay like first
yeah it's so funny now like it doesn't
matter to me cuz I can you can I have
money but back then it was like like
like panicking is like you have to pay
the first month and the last month's
rent up front and then it's like the
security deposit and then it's this and
then you have to and then like gas to
commute back and and all these kinds of
things and calculating all of this and
it's like oh well I guess I can't wear a
belt for a couple of weeks until my next
paycheck it's like that it sucks and uh
and so you know so there are times like
that where I'm like oh I could just buy
this without thinking about it and that
that part is nice um so I think it is
that kind of um you know like happiness
research will do this um what is it like
uh they have terms for this it's like
life life satisfaction versus um I think
they may just call it happiness where
like happiness is like your your actual
affective state in the moment dayto day
how much positive versus negative
emotion are you experienc subjectively
throughout the day or the week or
whatever and then there's the life
satisfaction component which is
basically when you step back and view
your life as a whole how satisfied are
you and those two things are correlated
but they're not quite the same in some
ways I think parents often report much
lower levels of happiness but higher
levels of Life satisfaction yes and and
I think in that regard it's like you
know my happiness I don't know if it's
actually changed much maybe there is a
bit of that honic adaptation where you
know 15 years ago it was like oh I can
you know I can go to Wendy's cool like
I'm happy whereas now it's um you know
something else and but but ultimately
that hasn't changed but the life
satisfaction I'm sure is is much higher
that like oh I've had a few
accomplishments and I can afford things
and I don't have to think about money as
much anymore and so yeah I think there
is that and yeah and also like
reminiscing too like when I talk to my
sister or some of my my old friends from
high school and just sort of thinking
about those days it's like you know I I
do feel a bit better now about my life I
was I was talking to a friend and uh
they were asking
me stuff about my childhood and my
memory is really Patchy from my
childhood it's not fantastic uh
especially not sort of pre1 and
um I said look like what what do you
remember I said well I remember a good
bit because of my sister because we'll
prompt each other about oh do you
remember that oh my God yeah we did do
that thing and and we were in that car
or we got stuck in the the mud or
whatever right and um yeah there's a
degree where I wonder how much is just
one good chat GPT prompt away from uh me
you know opening out into this really
beautiful answer about some insight or
whatever some experience that I had as a
kid um but yeah George Mack my friend
once a month lies in in bed before he
wakes up for 10 minutes and imagines
what it would be like to live with no
arms or legs that's one of his favorite
meditations among a a bunch of other
weird ones so he's trying to dial up
contrast as much as possible think about
all of the challenges that I would have
to face think about what this day is
going to entail think about all of the
things that would be difficult for me
think about how grateful I would be if
only I could just you know wash my own
back if only I could brush my own teeth
if only I could do these things so what
he's trying to do is is give himself
gratitude for the things that he takes
for Grant Ed that are very normal now
the interesting thing with your example
is that you don't need to imagine what
it would be like to live in squala MH
because you did yeah but the way that
our sense of self works you know what is
it every seven years every cell in your
body has turned over so there isn't even
you're like the two ship of thes three
three three ship of thesises away from
the person that you were then and even
for me now being in Austin for two years
I went back home for Christmas and it's
like it's kind of like a fever dream I'm
being back in this place that I know so
well but I'm different but I'm not and
then I find triggers environmental
triggers causing me to fall back into
other different ways of thinking and
stuff like that um so I was interested
in whether or not basically you have
been able to lock in a degree of
gratitude uh like relativistic gratitude
I suppose based on where you came from
to where you are now but it's a
permanent a permanent battle like in
some regards from from a poverty
perspective like you were a guy who was
born with no arms or legs and then grew
them yeah yeah I mean yeah
those I think that yeah that's that's
right where I where if I think about
what it was like back then and I compare
it to now of course like things are much
better for me and yeah I mean it's it
would be it would be I think shameful to
be anything other than completely
grateful and you know just full of
gratitude for proud as well I would like
to think yeah I mean that's a weird one
like the like you know I think when that
that's one of the things that you know
in the book I point this out that like
you know when you don't really grow up
with parents and you don't really I mean
because I grew up in foster homes before
I think like that CR there's like the
developmental window where if you don't
really receive like positive feedback
like I think I just like I receive
compliments in a very weird way where
it's like very hard for me to accept it
it's a skill it's a real skill man who
was it that I I gave someone a
compliment [__] I can't remember who it
was I gave somebody a complimen mhm and
I've never seen any I wish I could
remember who it was but it would
probably be a good idea that I couldn't
call them out in any case dude it's like
the worst way that I've ever seen anyone
take a compliment just you know you say
this thing that you think is a nice gift
that you're giving somebody and even
giving compliments is a skill that I've
had to learn because doing something
that's nice for somebody else is is a
nice thing to do um ginda it was [__]
ginda it was on an episode that I did
recently okay and uh I was like dude I
[__] I adore your writing I adore
your substack you've got two bucks
coming out I can't wait to read them I'm
fired up every single time I speak you
on the podcast I love it it's like a
it's a Fugue State we drop into for two
hours it's brilliant and I just saw his
face people can go watch the episode and
it's very it's very Charming like it's
very Charming because obviously he's he
holds himself to a high standard and
stuff like that but you see this guy go
like yeah thanks it's very it's very
Charming um well the other day I had
this this interaction with with one of
my friends mothers and uh and you know
she was like very high energy and she
was like oh you know Rob I love your
writing and now it's like I love your
substack and I watch you on you know
modern wisdom and it's like it's so
great and at first I was like you know
oh that's nice thank you you know trying
to like change the subject I just like I
feeling all these compliments and I just
feel uncomfortable I'm like that's
really nice of you thank you so much and
she's like no really she's like did you
really get a PhD from Cambridge cuz
that's amazing and then like I started
to walk away feeling like damn I feel
pretty good about myself actually like
you hang around all the time eventually
I was like you know I I was suddenly
getting this like really positive mom
energy and I was like this is great like
actually but it took a second right at
first I was like you know just fell into
that sort of default like oh very kind
of you to say thank you so much and then
she kept going with it and I'm like wow
this is a really nice lady you're like a
kind of the equivalent of of a really
obesely overweight person who can't just
go in the gym and do a little bit it's
like hey we've got to shift 250 you need
to stay on that treadmill for another
hour mister you finish and you're like
oh wow like exactly exactly there's like
a crushing weight of compliments that
you need but that's something I'd love
I've got
um who wrote no more No More Mr Nice Guy
Robert Glover thank you I've got Dr
Robert Glover coming on the show soon
I'm very excited to speak to him and um
I'd love to talk about the uh the skill
of both accepting and uh giving
compliments I think that that's a really
underrated skill uh the the ability to
give an Earnest compliment
and to graciously but honestly receive
it right skill that no one really ever
talks about that is interesting yeah I
think for it's at least my impression is
it's actually easier to deliver a
compliment than to receive way easier
because you can be sincere about it like
you can honestly show your appreciation
if you enjoy something to tell someone
but yeah I've I've yes seen this seems
to be a common pattern that people have
difficulty with with receiving them more
so with guys maybe um than than girls
although
that's an interest that's an interesting
one cuz with women for sure they they
hide ambition uh they downplay success
and stuff like that uh certainly female
to female communication I think there is
uh more opaqueness and more [__] that
goes on with regards to that if a guy
thinks that you've done something [__]
they go dude that was lame whereas it
might be couched in some other sort of
language from a woman um yeah that' be
interesting I'd love someone to look at
uh sincere versus insincere compliments
from comparing men and women that would
be fascinating study this morning I was
um I was prepping a newsletter it'll go
out tomorrow uh you know I do like the
three you know interesting findings
everyone needs to go to Rob substack and
subscribe I it's outstanding thank you
man and I I shamelessly repurpose at
least one thing every like couple of
weeks I think like well the figh he
deserved as as wide an audience as
possible but this was an interesting one
it'll go out um where so this was a
study from 1988 I I'd be curious to see
like I don't I couldn't find anything
more recent but essentially they broke
down by gender um the domain of of of
where people deliver their compliments
and so for women it was uh when women
compliment women versus when men
compliment men what are they
complimenting for women it was mostly
appearance it was like something like
60% of the compliments were about
appearance and then it was like 15%
about possessions and 10% about
accomplishments and that kind of thing
whereas so it was mostly appearance
based for women when they're
complimenting one another whereas for
men it was mostly based on uh
accomplishments uh most of their uh
compliments to one another were about
accomplishments and so one thing that I
would wonder is like maybe it's um I
wonder if it's kind of easier or or more
difficult depending on so so I would
imagine like for women when they receive
compliments about their appearance
because it seems to be the most common
domain that they would receive those
quite easily because they're used to it
whereas for accomplishments that makes
them feel uncomfortable in some way if
youy if I go to you and I'm like dude
you're looking buff like exactly tell me
about tell me about how good my last
newsletter was yeah yeah yeah yeah I
wonder if like we would feel more
uncomfortable when it's something other
than than the typical Target that's so
fascinating and yet again it shows just
how people people's behavior zeros in on
the most Salient parts of each sex's uh
characteristics so women are
complementing the most important thing
to the opposite sex men are
complimenting the most important thing
to the opposite sex the same thing
happens with derogation as well you know
if there's an argument between a guy and
a woman on the internet the woman's
going to say he's got small dick energy
and the guy's going to call her a slag
right that's it it's like I'm going to
derate your Chastity I'm going to
derogate your sexual prowess I'm going
to say that you're not as competent or
as rich or as good-looking or as like uh
successful as you think you are and I'm
going to say that you're like fatter
older and uglier than you are why well
those are the most important things that
you have with regards to social currency
and these are the same people who will
throw these sorts of insults around like
you know Greta tbug accused Andrew Tate
of having small dick energy like it's I
think it's the third most liked tweet of
all time or something like that I think
she's I think she's in the top 10 twice
and I think Tate features in the top 10
twice or three times and at least maybe
one or two of those are his interactions
with Greta tumberg so kind of I don't
know
like he's like the Michael Jackson to
her Jan Jackson or something like very
very successful when they get together
yeah that is yeah like where I think
that yeah the same people who would
probably endorse like some form of
gender blank Slade egalitarianism or
deny that there are any sort of
biologically based sex differences will
still sort of Target those areas of
inity it's the same as the Harvard
Extension school thing right yeah yeah
so yeah that's yeah so if um yeah if
you're you know a very Progressive
person but then a man is an knowing you
online you'll immediately start telling
him that he's you know a virgin or he's
you know exactly [__] incel like okay
well inel yeah if you throw that debate
around speaking of that uh Alexander
daty just put a new study out did you
see this one he hasn't released the
details but he's capturing the data at
the moment on it through a Google form
and it's so funny he's put um videos up
asking participants to rank the
attractiveness of different red pill
influencers okay so there's the guys
from fresh and fit um uh uh who else is
in there I don't know there's like a
bunch of other people that are in there
and uh it's got the replies are so funny
I got to look at so it's on it's on
Twitter like these these him mining for
the dayri is on Twitter the results
aren't he's he's he only put it out
yesterday I think I got to look at this
this is hilarious I dude I have to is he
on there iess I'm not I'm not and he's
not he went like more kind of like I
don't know the big names within that
world or whatever
but
um he is Alex has an
ability I don't think I've ever seen you
get into a spat on
Twitter I don't think you've ever had it
back and forth despite having like
hundreds of thousands of people that
follow you uh
ginda likes to kind of he's more like a
Hitman so he'll sit up on a ridge snip
and look out and then he'll like fire
something and it's like AOC it'll be
like a single reply to AOC with 500
likes from him and then nothing he won't
tweet for another
week he honestly he pops he pops out of
the Wilderness looks and he like adjust
the site fires and then leaves um but I
mean Alexander goes in with incel's in
incel co uh that account that I think is
the admin of the incels.co uh thing he's
back and forth with like anyone like egg
a non accounts like if he sees and
you've got this essay and it's really
well written but um his capacity he's
kind of like the destiny of dating
research you know he's just got this
predisposition that's very good for
being able to put up for anyone that
doesn't know who we're talking about
he's been in the show Alexander daty I
think it's like Alex daty on on Twitter
just look whatever day this goes out on
look at who he's are going tweets and
replies and have a look at how many
people he's arguing with and I promise
you there'll just be mountains M like
tons and tons and tons and it's no it's
nobody and then sometimes it's to
somebody but yeah um I think he's
performing a much needed service because
I don't have the patience for that um I
think like you know professors and
researchers and podcast like just people
who have like a million things to do and
I think like but he he's he's doing it
very well and he's building an audience
this way and I think you know it's it's
he's channeling his his knowledge and
his research toward productive ends and
you know I I think it it someone should
be engaging with a lot of these like
black pills you know these people high
priced do you see that we got lumped
into uh we we got given a name we did me
you William Costello and Alexander daty
and it's the academic manosphere okay
good company I like it I think that's a
that's a pretty good I was in there
really yeah I think so I think you were
it was a long time ago on this thing it
was like maybe months ago and I did
forgot to send it to you but yeah the
academic the academic manosphere types
it was used as a slur but I was like yo
if you want this to be a make it less
cool of a name like that's [__] dope
I would to be a part of the academic
manosphere yeah yeah I got I got lumped
in a couple of years ago with it was
some like you know like someone was like
trying to create like a league of the
IDW this was back when the IDW was still
I think I think it was still a thing
where it was kind of on the way down it
was like 2020
2021 um and yeah it was like in the
minor leagues it was like you know there
were Heavy Hitters you know Eric
Weinstein it back then I I don't know
what I had like followers or St they it
was like that would been probably after
your University of Austin thing maybe or
around about that time it was before
then even it was like you know I think
you and I had just met and it was like
still kind of early days and uh I was
looking at this I'm like I don't want to
you know like yeah I like some of the
people who are were whatever I don't
know if it's not really still a thing
anymore but I like some of those people
like I'm not really in this IDW thing
like I thought it was kind of yeah so
talking about you moving into the real
you know upper Stratosphere troposphere
of of class moving through your time in
uh the Air Force what about when you got
to Yale first and then Cambridge what
was some of the conventions that really
sort of stood out to you because I think
this has informed a lot of your ability
to sit back and and look at these
Dynamics and go oh isn't that
interesting because you have an
anchoring bias to be able to compare it
to you're like I saw this thing and then
I saw this and then I saw that so I'm
actually able to observe these Dynamics
for what they are rather than kind of I
get to see code rather than Matrix as
opposed to have only ever grown up
inside of the Matrix oh I see yeah yeah
I mean I so yeah I red uh on campus
2015 uh as an you know mature student
and uh Asian so looking like a normal
age I think I had the beard back then so
I had like a full beard you know so this
is like a very common thing with vets
where like cuz you have to shave every
day mil and they like inspect you to
make sure it's like it better be like
this morning you shaved not last night
kind of thing and uh and so as soon as I
got I'm like you know [__] sh months I
didn't work out dude I think I gained
like 20 lbs like it the first semester
was bad where I was like I was like I
don't have to work out anymore I don't
have to sh yeah it was really nice and
then like I know I like looked in the
mirror like six months in I was like I
got to Fig this is horrible um but the
first six months it was glorious um and
so but yeah I I looked older I was older
and you know the students some of them
would crack jokes about 21 Jump Street
you know like that kind of thing thing
and um yeah it was I think the first
couple of months or so nothing really
unusual but
then I saw this very strange uh you know
I mentioned before like witnessed the
kind of birth of this
new politically correct movement where a
professor had written an email
essentially defending freedom of
expression on campus it later became
known as the Yale Halloween Halloween
costume controversy uh on campus where
this was October uh the Yale
Administration released this email
basically telling the students to you
know not engage in any cultural
appropriation don't wear costumes that
would be offensive to these groups and
then uh one of the faculty members on
campus basically wrote an email just to
her students in her Residential College
saying like do we really need the
administration interfering in our lives
like you're all adults I trust that if
you wear things that maybe you don't
other people don't like you guys can
just work it out amongst yourselves
essentially defending freedom of Express
ression and in response hundreds of
students marched around campus calling
for her to be fired and later for her
husband Nicholas Christus to be fired um
saying that she was racist she was
defending cultural appropriation these
students claim they didn't feel safe on
campus and they were using this kind of
language uh which I think like now all
of this stuff is kind of Spilled Out of
the universities and we're all kind of
familiar with all this sort of
victimhood stuff but back then I was
just completely like flumix that you
know it was like we're in danger we you
know they caused us pain suffering we're
under immense harm uh you know this is
like a emblematic of you know broader
systemic forces that are working against
and I'm looking at these students and
like I know for a fact a lot of them
were the sons and daughters of
millionaires um I remember asking one uh
young female student basically like can
you explain like why is this offensive I
don't understand and she basically told
me I was too privileged to understand
why you know why Erica Chris' email was
offensive wow and you know she was like
some white girl who like went to private
boarding school that like grew up in a
rich neighborhood and but she was an
activist and whatever and so she was
like kind of the is it the T titiana
McGrath like that archetype uh except
like you know went to Yale and
everything and so um and that was like
an interesting thing too was like on
campus the whole identity politics idea
was that if you are a member of these
certain sociological categories then
therefore you are conferred legitimacy
to opine on all of the social ills of
the world and how to fix them and so on
but then the students also placed a
great deal of importance on lived
experience you know and if you live
through something in your life then
therefore you're able to speak about
certain things you're an authority on
those matters but those two things seem
to be to me contradictory that you know
does it matter what you live through in
your life or does does it just matter
like what you what category you belong
to isn't it interesting that you had
17year Squall of legitimacy when it
comes to lived experience but the number
one thing which is ignored is class yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly and it was I
mean is yeah
they because there are so few people who
had my kind of background on campus and
because so few students and graduates of
these kinds of universities ever
encounter it it just isn't on their
radar that they don't even think about I
mean what's really interesting was that
Yale is located in New Haven which is a
really lowincome kind of blue collar
town but you know they call it the Yale
bubble where you know the students would
only stick around in this very sort of
you know enclosed area but I lived off
campus uh in an apartment downtown and
so I would walk through like a lot of
poverty a lot of squalor a lot of
addiction and you know having you know
20 minutes earlier heard some student
talk about how they were oppressed and
then I'd see you know real uh poverty
and real suffering and it was just very
difficult for me to sort of reconcile
those things and eventually like At
first I tried to be sympathetic and
tried to understand these you know these
these Grievances and the the students
and the graduates and the faculty and
all the you know and then eventually I
was like these people have you know they
they just completely don't understand
they have no connection with it
whatsoever and I'm some of it I think is
legitimately
malicious and duplicitous I would see
for
example people claim that investment
Banks were emblematic of capitalist
depression and say that you know these
are just you know the horrible entities
and then those same people would be at a
recruitment session for Goldman Sachs
like two weeks later and I think like
you know that to me was like that was a
calculated move like and what I mean by
that is like you don't want to work for
them yeah like if if they can basically
eliminate their Rivals for these
prestigious internships then all the
better for them and so I think some of
it was tactical and calculated but I
think for a lot of people it's just um
you know their hearts are in the right
place or they're not really thinking
that much about it um and so yeah this
was uh yeah it was very strange and then
and the other thing is so this is funny
I um I I never knew my father growing up
and I didn't know who he was or anything
about him um and it was only recently I
took a 23 in me and got the results and
found that my father uh was Mexican and
I went through I I called up our our
mutual friend roseb Khan I was like hey
can you look at this with me and like
help explain he's like yeah your dad was
like you know Mexican he's like
indigenous from North America with some
Spanish ancestry like that's like a perf
he's like you grew up in La M like what
did you expect and uh I was like okay so
my dad was Mexican but so when I was at
Yale before I had this information I was
hanging out in a dorm room with some
students and it was a friend of mine who
was a Mexican guy and you know he he was
not like a you know he wasn't an
activist he wasn't like woke or whatever
but I took a sombrero off the wall and
put it on my head and he he was joking
around but he said something like hey
you know that's culture appropriation
you can't wear that somero I was like oh
my bad you know joking around and then
once I got these results back I was like
wait a minute I'm allowed to I could
wear that some to wear some get me a
poncho get me some fajitas and then and
then the next thought I had was yeah but
the next thought I had was like this
just shows how like how stupid the whole
thing is in the first place right like
someone from my background who didn't
know my father who could have been like
I could have believe like if I had
believed in the cultural appropriation
thing I could have bought into it and
now what am I supposed to think now that
I have these DNA test results and then I
you know just like the whole idea of
like breaking people down into like
these ethnic categories and they are or
are not allowed to partake in this
activity or that or the other um like
when when there are people out there who
actually don't know who their fathers
are or don't know um they don't even
know what cultural appropriation means I
just think like our our attention and
our resources and our time are spent on
such such frivolous nonsense what is it
the the tyranny of small differences
what's that thing uh yeah the narcissism
of small differ narcism of small
differences that's it yeah yeah yeah
that the smaller the differences between
people the bigger that they're blown up
to be when you have this relatively
homogeneous group of people at Yale it's
all to do with you can't speak to her
like that it's like why like
she's she's exactly the same as you just
that one grandmother
half African-American or something yeah
yeah yeah and and everyone is from like
the top probably the top desis of income
I mean at Yale there are more students
from the top 1% of the income scale than
from the entire bottom
60% like almost everybody is either I
mean and like yeah this is an
interesting point that narcissism of
small differences where a lot of the
anger I felt was it was like between
like someone at the 90th percentile
income who they were angry at that 99th
percentile right like you know whatever
like someone from a family of whatever
doctors and lawyers who are sort of
upper middle class who are angry that
the children of billionaires get to do
something a little more expensive or a
little bit more you know they get to go
on a more expensive vacation or you know
like all of that was was very much
confined with people who are extremely
affluent and welltoo and then there were
you know a handful of people like me I
mean I I'm the only one who had like the
kind of life that I had but I knew some
people from more kind of blue collar
backgrounds the underclass bonafides
yeah yeah exactly who are really just
kind of like lower middle class Blue
Collar but not not like I mean it's the
thing is like the way that the system
works is I think we might have talked
about this last time about just how few
people um like only less than 3% of
foster kids graduate from University
less than 3% um and you know people who
are from the bottom income quintile it's
it's 11% and so you know really there
are more you're four times more likely
to graduate from college if you're poor
than if you live through the Foster
system I mean that's just how you the
odds are so stacked against you and so
yeah I mean even the people I knew who
so I think I was one of like eight
veterans on campus you know people think
of the military as like oh kind of like
people who maybe didn't go to college or
people who had maybe sort of a more Hard
Scrabble life um which is maybe to some
extent true compared to people who go to
expensive colleges but I was so I was
one of eight military vets on campus but
even when I would interact with the
other vets uh enlisted vets
um in my cohort so there were yeah eight
in my cohort and I would I would speak
with them I was like oh like basically
all of them were raised by two parents
and like you know had a mom and a dad
who did prioritize education and who you
know kind of said good examples and you
know all of those things and I think
yeah we focus a lot on I think the left
focus is a lot on economics I think
certain strands of the right will focus
on behavioral genetics but there is this
sort of cultural component here too that
people don't really seem to to want to
touch at some point I will write write
this this this post up about
sort of the the limitations of sort of
overextending the findings of of
behavioral genetics I think like it's an
important thing to to know and to
understand and to sort of be fluent in
but also to to not discount the role of
good habits Customs sort of good good
behaviors I wrote this post um nobody's
a prisoner of their IQ and I think
that's an important uh piece too that
it's true that the guys I grew up with
regardless of their parenting or
whatever uh their economic conditions
were they probably weren't going to be
um in a position to go to a very
expensive you know selective University
but I think if they had been maybe
taught different uh values and
inculcated different habits that you
know two of them wouldn't have gone to
prison one of them was shot to death uh
friends working sort of meal low-income
jobs I mean that's the sort of typical
outcome of people in that community and
I don't think like maybe we can't
necessarily raise the ceiling for some
people we can definitely raise the floor
I think yeah and so the last one of the
last episodes I did in this room was
with Destiny and he prompted this idea
that I named two-step potential Theory
which is a blending of individual agency
with real world limitations your efforts
have tons of control over your outcome
within the range that your world's
limitations will allow behavioral
genetics teaches us that on average
around 50% of everything that we are
psychologically is inherited from our
parents boo 50% of our outcomes are
limited by our genetics
yes but that also means that 50% of them
are up to you which is great this is
another reason to not only compare
yourself to who you were yesterday not
to who someone else is today but it's
also a reason to try lots of things
until you find the intersection of
something that you love and something
that you're good at and um yeah it's
like you can imagine that you have a
bracket within which your potential sits
mhm and that bracket is determined very
heavily by outside forces it's genetic
predisposition its life circum ances
it's nutrition it's upbringing it's
[__] unconscious trauma it's all the
epigenetics it's all of that stuff but
your position within that window is
almost exclusively on you now that
window also determines your ability to
deploy your efforts right but that just
moves the window that doesn't move you
within the window Yeah well yeah James
CLA has this nice line in atomic habits
about how certain people become so
preoccupied with their genetic
limitations that they never try to
actually reach them I love that yeah
it's it's incred right that and I think
people understand this at least in the
context of like physical fitness right
it's like well I'm never going to look
like Arnold Schwarzenegger so I'm just
not going to go to the gym which is like
a completely uh misguided way to think
about things um but yeah I like this
like yeah that that line about sort of
behavioral genetics but then also there
is individual agency involved and you do
have some control over this I mean I
even I just wrote this post about melli
and how um in the discourses on Livy he
writes about uh how you know he
basically says God doesn't want to do
everything he's like some of it is up to
you you this he was in a much more
religious time than we are uh living in
Italy and C you know Catholic Florence
and God doesn't want to do everything
but then but then he says you know
basically 50% of your outcomes are due
to Fortune 50% of your outcomes are due
to your own individual efforts and
Fortune will favor you if you take
action these kinds of things there's a
there's a political philosopher Harvey
Mansfield who actually suggested that
this this transition uh indicates that
makell may have been an atheist because
at first he starts out saying God
doesn't want to do everything and then
he starts saying 50% is fortunate and
50% is you well where does that leave
room for God and mlli may have been sort
of subtly indicating to the reader that
you know you can talk about God you can
think about God but ultimately it's
going to be luck and it's going to be
you and that's all you have could have
got his percentages wrong yeah or
exactly yeah so one of the things I
looked at your end of your review that
you did and that actually reminded me
that I hadn't done mine uh as in the
breakdown of what were the 10
I think he did the 10 most read free
articles and paid articles which will
still be up on your website and people
can go and check that out and that
prompted me while I was back home in the
UK that [__] I haven't done mine for
modern wisdom so thank you for that um
but the best read article that you had
last year was one called how I read yeah
and there's this great screenshot from
talb in there talb says the opposite of
reading is not not reading but reading
something like the New Yorker I love
that line so much what do you think he
means by that um you know TB is so that
you know there a screenshot from Twitter
I think there's you know there is the
sort of Twitter TB and then there's the
the author there's different you know
there's different versions of him but I
the way that I interpreted that you know
the contener tweet from TB was that
um you know if if reading is defined as
you know consuming useful important
Timeless
information uh than you know reading you
know the sort of hot takes in you know
like Legacy Media institutions you know
often you know colored by bias colored
by the ideologies of our time that you
know that's actually the opposite of
getting useful you know important
Timeless information you're getting sort
of unuseful unimportant uh timely you
know relevant maybe in the moment and
then tomorrow people for will forget all
about it and so I think that's kind of
what he meant here um and you know to be
fair like I I I wrote in there that I do
enjoy reading the New Yorkers sometimes
but but not as much as I enjoy that
tweet yeah yeah yeah yeah what's your
advice for people who want to become
better readers uh I mean it's a it's a
habit you know I've been sort of sort of
you know touching on this on this uh
idea of discipline of habit of agency
and I think it's it's similar to a gym
routine right where when you're starting
out it's it's difficult it's um you know
sort of building it into your schedule
but then once you get going um it
becomes much easier to just sort of set
it and forget it that you know from
these hours from this time of day I'm
I'm you know I'm going to the gym and
here's the workout and here's the
routine and now you don't have to think
about it anymore that sort of discipline
equals Freedom
idea um and so I did that with reading
I've really been kind of a on and off
reader since I was a kid um I taught
myself how to read in the foster homes
and then reading became this kind of uh
like the soothing experience for me that
I could sort of you know disconnect from
the world and learn about information
and yeah yeah exactly and so I would do
that um um and so it's always been a
sort of a companion for me but you
know with with you know everyone gets
busy everyone has a million things that
they have to do they have work they have
obligations but for reading yeah it
really does you really have to treat it
like a gym routine or like a job or
something like an important habit set
time aside every day and so this is what
I was doing in in grad school was you
know first thing in the morning I'd have
my cup of coffee and I try to read
whatever you know five pages 10 pages 15
pages whatever it is um if people don't
really have the reading habit at all I
do like James clea's idea of like start
from like the lowest unit of effort
possible like sentence yeah sentence
yeah yeah I mean it would be really
weird if you started from the word level
but yeah sentence level or a paragraph
level you know ideally you could get a
page in uh you know something
substantive um and then build your way
from there uh whether it's a chapter
whether it's a book and so on and I
think yeah breaking it down in that way
is helpful because you know I speak to
some people who want to read and they're
like okay I'm going to try to finish
this book this week or I'm going to try
to finish this book this month and I
think like thinking in those terms isn't
really helpful I think you have to break
it down further of instead of a book a
month I'm going to read three pages a
day or 10 pages a day and then you'll
finish the book when it gets finished um
the other thing is if a book is
uninteresting to you or it's not holding
your attention to just let it go you
know it's fine you don't have to read it
just because you bought it or because
you rented it from the library or what
have you it's because everybody else
says that it's good or because you read
on Twitter that It's really informative
or you want to tell other people that
you've read it that they've read it as
well right and yeah you don't I mean
that's one of the that was one of the
things that I learned too was um you
know a lot of people a lot of the sort
of chattering class people they will not
read the books that they claim to have
read but they'll read reviews and so if
you want to just like know about a book
to participate in a conversation just go
read three or four reviews online uh and
that'll sort of give you the highlights
of what people are talking about or what
what the takeaways are that people care
about from the book but if you really
want to do a deep dive if you really
want to understand a book then yeah you
have to read the whole thing cover to
cover but you know take it slow do what
you're comfortable with if you want to
skip around that's fine too that if a
particular chapter title sticks out at
you or seems to be especially
provocative or interesting start with
that chapter first and then you can go
back I would recommend for most books
especially most older books to actually
read the um the preface the you know
author's note the forward because for a
lot of sort of older texts you know I
mentioned Mak Val earlier you know it it
does help that those you know the the
the prologue and all those kinds of
things they will sort of contextualize
the book and sort of explain to some
degree why is this book important why do
people care about it what's been the
sort of commentary a summary of of this
author's influence throughout the
centuries and so I do recommend reading
that and not just skipping to chapter
one um and yeah I mean there there are
other things too that um you can read
multiple books simultaneously there's no
rule in place I think we learned from
school that one book at a time you know
read this and hear the the formula for
how you read um but actually you can do
whatever you want skip around read two
pages of this book put it down you know
take a week off read this other book for
a while I'll do that when I'm on
vacation I'll just start a new book even
if I'm working on three other books back
home I'll just pick up a new book off
the shelf and go on vacation and that'll
be my vacation book I do weird things
like that and for me it's helpful um and
and the other thing is it's helpful to
take notes too um whether it's in the
book itself people get mad at me
sometimes on Twitter they're like oh
you're defacing that book like oh
[__] bought it my book ex exactly
yeah it's not like I'm vandalizing you
know it's there's a there's a really
good book um called how to read a book
called Mortimer Adler by Mortimer Adler
and um he's um he was a professor at the
University of Chicago uh in the mid mid
late 20th century but he wrote this book
basically like explaining the different
forms of reading the different types of
reading and this is where I picked up a
lot of this information about it's okay
to skip around what are your goals for
reading um Break Down The Habit
but one of the points he's made is that
no one M he he makes this analogy he
says no one mistakes the uh what do they
called in in in the composers of music
like the sheet the sheet music or
something no one confuses that for the
melody itself right it's like no one's
you know it's not the paper is not
sacred the ideas on them are sacred and
most authors would be flattered if
someone was so invested in the book and
the topic that they're engag their own
[__] yeah and the marginalia
like yeah I mean it's it's you see this
with like if you visit museums you know
Cambridge they have like Darwin's notes
or his scribblings of other people's
texts and you can see like he was
reading and he was making notes and and
he was doing this in a time where uh it
was actually harder to get books than it
is now um and so engage with the book um
try to understand what the points are in
the book don't just I mean this is
something that I used to do even though
I was a reader I didn't
really I didn't really um try to
understand what the book was about
before I started it it was like oh
here's an interesting title and I'd read
the back of it and it would be oh it's
about XYZ and I okay I'll just start
reading it and sort of fumble my way
through rather than think about okay
where's this author coming from what
point is he trying to make uh why is
this book important try to take that
sort of metal level perspective as well
so that you can really understand where
he's coming from and break down the
points if you really want to um
especially for more modern social
science books
one thing you can do is essentially just
read the first and last chapter or the
preface in the last chapter because you
know that's just the way that's just a
style of reading or style of writing now
where you know Publishers want you to
just basically summarize the idea at the
beginning and the end for busy people
for tired people what's this book about
you know like what are you going to talk
about and then at the end say here's
what I talked about and that'll sort of
give you you know maybe 50% what a funny
hack that's so funny what about uh
revisiting things because you're
recall seems to be quite impressive
which is something that people want they
want to reading something and then not
being able to recall what you read is
kind of in some ways like not having
read it at
all yeah well I think taking notes
highlighting and then what I'll do is
like you know I'll have like a Google
doc or some kind of uh notetaking app
where I'll like cut and paste if it's
like Kindle version or if it's the paper
version I'll sometimes I'll just post it
on Twitter um and then that'll be like
the search function where I can find it
later um or I can um yeah I'll just you
don't get deleted from Twitter would
it's not the access to the audience it's
my own arive of my notes exactly that
would be that would be rough yeah yeah
um and so yeah so I think that sharing
it in that way and that's actually how
my Twitter started was me just sharing
notes and things I was reading that's
like how the initial sort of growth
occurred was you know I was in I think
it was in undergrad when I started it in
yeah 2017 um posting my notes online and
my highlights and underline
and um and so yeah I think like
pinpointing the interesting points doing
like a very brief summary even it's
literally one sentence preferably a
paragraph if you finish a book like what
did you get from this book what are two
or three things that you remember right
now having just finished readit because
if you if you have just finished reading
a book the most important or interesting
or provocative points will be at the top
of your mind just try to paraphrase it
don't even go back to the book and say
well what did he actually say try to say
what did I remember type it out try to
use that that forced recall and that'll
help to um to to sort of get it into
longterm memory and then every once in a
while like if I'm flying on a plane or
if I'm you know in waiting in line or
something usually I'll read a book but
sometimes I'll actually just revisit my
notes and say you know what did that
book say or what was that point and do
like a control F if I just want to read
about what mating psychology or what
have you I'll just do the the control F
and okay here are my notes on mating
Psychology from David bus or this book
or that book and that'll help me to just
sort of connect the dots and and uh and
and also help to provide material for my
substack which is most important
obviously Rob I appreciate the hell out
of you it's very good to speak to you
again I'm so happy that this book's
finally out it's taken forever yeah it's
been five years plus yeah and the making
yeah that this has been going and then
it's been ready to be published for a
good while as well and you've been sort
of held at the starting line so where
should people go they want to check out
the book The substack the everything
else what um yeah they can get my book
troubled uh a mem care family and social
class that's you know wherever wherever
books are sold and yeah follow me on
Twitter robk Henderson subr
henderson.com hell yeah thanks Rob thank
you Chris if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe